now Russian President Vladimir Putin is
making his annual address to the federal
assembly it comes just days before the
first anniversary of the invasion of
Ukraine let's take a listen in
and um I would remind you that in 2014
the key of regime put all their
resources with the military weapons and
tanks um to the area Ogden bus
in 2015. they started again an attempt
to direct and bus directly
besieging them and
terrorizing uh people living there and
all of that contradicted the agreed
resolutions and agreements in place
and we I would like to repeat that they
started this war and we use all our
strengths to stop it
[Applause]
we're going to destroy Crimea next and
we knew about it we knew about the plans
and in keys they now say about it openly
we knew it anyway
our country our people and the West
already spent
150 billion dollars for supporting cave
regime
and G
iven
allocated
only 60 billion dollars for supporting
poor countries
so you know what I mean they spend 150
billion dollars for supporting uh
military actions in Ukraine but only 60
million to support poor countries to
fight poverty or to develop ecology
where all of these um good work
disappeared
and they keep putting plants into a fuel
in this wall
recently at the Munich conference
they repressively uh
the keys does
um
in order to ensure that the whole world
forgets what the West has done over the
last 10 years they let the gene out of
the bottle
the genie out of the bottom they left
ago and we didn't make out um all those
data figures that we have
and about 38 million people became
refugees now
they just want to erase it from
the memory of humanity trying to make it
act like nothing happened but nobody
forgot what happened with the human
losses and tragedies
they just try to
use these principles of democracy and
freedom in order to defend their uh in
fact totalitarian values
and they just try to uh
distract people's attention from
corruption scandals
you can see it's on the news all the
time uh to distract people from economic
and social problems and contradictions
and difficulties
I will remind you that the West opened
the way for Nazism in the 1930s
and people who know a little bit at
least about history they know that it
goes back into 19th century
back to Australian Empire and Poland
and they tried to take those um
territories that are today called
Ukrainian they were trying to take those
territories from us so
nothing new really
supported the coup d'etat in 2014 that
was a bloody coup d'etat and they made
it out like nothing happened
they even informed us how much money
they spent
and they put some um
this hatred for all Russian
into this um
they blamed us
um as comparing us to um Hitler's
actions
and they use this um
and other Notions
military tanks and equipment they use um
this uh Nazi signs
unbelievable that um nobody in uh the
west and countries
um realizes or notices this and why
because they don't care I'm sorry but
they care only about fighting us the
Russians
as long as they fight Russia
they can use um Devil Himself so that
they just fight Russia
and now the only aim was to
um start the war in Europe with somebody
else's hands and get rid of the
competitors we don't fight with the
Ukrainian people I said that many times
before
Ukrainian people became
um of hostages of this scheme regime
that occupied of Ukraine both
economically
and politically
over years they were
make doing everything to
um material yeah bring this degradation
nobody cared about people there
and um in the end they just are using
their people
um it's very sad but um it's true and
um who is responsible for um this
conflict for it the responsibility is on
the West's and of course on the
Ukrainian Elite and their government uh
Ukrainian governments today does not
serve uh national interests it serves
the interests of these third countries
and they use Ukraine as a military base
for fighting Russia
I'm not going to go into detail about
increases of their actions to build up
their um weapons but the more they send
weapons to Ukraine the more we will have
to respond to the security situation on
the borders of Russia that's a natural
reaction and response
they don't even hide their
intentions in the west they say they
need to cause strategic and for Russia
what do they mean they mean to um and
with us to move the local conflict into
the uh phase of global um
fight
and we understand what's happening and
we will respond
to this because
in this case we're already talking about
existence of our country but they should
realize that it's impossible to um to
win
against Russia on the battlefield that's
why they use the information
um
sphere to Fighters
and they keep lying they constantly
constantly
attack our cultural values
Orthodox Church look what they do today
that's uh Vladimir Putin delivering his
annual address to both houses of
Russia's Parliament regarding the
conflict in Ukraine he said they started
this war and we used all our strength to
stop it he also said the
responsibilities on the west and the
Ukrainian government
let's go to Osama bin jabid now in
Moscow so pretty much so far the defiant
competitive speech that we were perhaps
expecting
indeed President Vladimir Putin began by
detailing the inevitability of War as
he'd like to tell his people that it is
not Russia which initiated this war he'd
like to tell people that Russia was
negotiating in good faith in the Minsk
one in the men's two agreements which he
says Western Powers have now said that
they were actually buying time and he
accuses the best of uh going behind
being behind the Nazis as he'd like to
call them and it was important for
Russia to de-nutsify its border and he's
been detailing at length on how the
world has failed the people of the world
by the billions of dollars 150 billion
dollars he says have freely flowed into
Ukraine where only a few hundred million
have gone into helping others so
according to President Vladimir Putin a
combative speech he is coming out as the
commander-in-chief of the forces a year
after his forces went into Ukraine a
year after Russia has taken over more
more territory in its West and towards
Ukraine's East and today also marks the
day of the Don yes people Republic's uh
referendum which was called sham so
again a large audience of 1400 people in
Moscow listening to him screens put up
in all major cities in all time zones
across Russia so that the people can
hear Vladimir Putin come out defend his
operation tell his people why he had to
go to war and why he's not backing down
okay well Zane as Ravi is uh live for us
now in the Ukrainian Capital key Zayn
how will the Ukrainian leadership be
viewing the contents of this speech so
far
well as you know we've been covering
this war since day one of the invasions
since even before that and listening to
the speech here in Kiev what leaders are
also likely to see from this speech is
that nothing has really changed there's
been no change of narrative he hasn't
said anything that he hasn't said in the
past to try to uh really validate why
this Invasion had to happen from the
Russian side and Ukrainian leaders are
likely to see this as just another day
just another day of Vladimir Putin
continuing to reiterate what are old
points and really the government here
has diplomatically at least while the
war is still going on diplomatically
this is a very different Ukraine from
what it was a year ago they have really
moved on and one thing that has happened
win or lose Ukraine now has a seat at a
few different tables at the table of
Western allies at the table with NATO
they're not members yet but they're on
that they're at that table and they're
at the EU table socially politically
economically Ukraine has pivoted hard
towards the West which is perhaps the
opposite of what the Russian leadership
had hoped to accomplish Us by this
Invasion but that is what has happened
and now whatever happens with the war
next Ukraine is squarely pivoting West
they're at the table with their Western
analyze and that's something unlikely to
change no matter what direction the
battles on the front continue to go in
okay Zane brazavi thank you for that
well joining us here on set is
director of policy analysis at the Arab
Center for research and policy studies
you're very welcome
um thank you what has stood out so far
for you from this speech uh uh I think
he started
by justifying the war because I think
the whole decision to go to war was
based on miscalculations first of all he
and he overstated the power of the
Russian military
he underestimated the power of the
Ukraine military he underestimated the
resolve of the western Powers mainly the
United States and the European Union to
stand up against the invasion and also I
think he underestimated the will of the
Europeans to free themselves from being
blackmailed by Russian energy supplies
so I think all these put together
is making him now trying to justify this
decision to his own people because now
he cannot tell the people of Russia any
good news about this because this
special what he called special military
operation has been going on now for for
almost a year exactly a year tomorrow
and the objectives have not been
achieved I.E he couldn't remove the
government of Vladimir zielinski that
was the first objective of the of the
war
he is not preventing the expansion of
NATO because as we all know the truth
that Ukraine is not part of NATO until
now but we all know that Sweden and
Finland are going to be soon members of
of NATO
so I think I think here he needed he
needed to see something he needed to say
something to the to the Russian people
who are wondering now if the decision to
go to war was the right decision so he
said that he was trying to say that I
had no option I was forced actually to
go into Ukraine because there was no
other no other no other way no other
alternative for me despite that I mean
how infuriated would Russia have been by
Joe Biden's visit to keep with that of
increased drama Putin's resolve in this
I think this is what he tried to show
during his his speech because he said
that this this military operation will
continue until objectives are are
achieved or realized eyes so he must be
very Furious by the U.S support to
Ukraine and visit by President Biden
yesterday to give it although highly
symbolic in terms of supporting because
the support has already been boring into
Ukraine for for many months now and
perhaps the military support the Ukraine
received from the United States has
never been given to any other country
for for almost since since the second
world war so I think he is angry and he
believes that the United States and NATO
is fighting Russia this is a war by
proxy against Russia he said they are
using Ukraine in order to weaken Russia
in order to attack Russia and this is
something he will not tolerate according
to what he said today
you were in Doha a year ago just before
Russia's Invasion on a special panel
could you have imagined where we are
today I think from the very beginning it
was for for many of us the decision was
not the right decision because some
actually believe that the Americans who
have been expecting uh the Russian
invasion since last year actually they
had been preparing their allies in in
Ukraine to to confront
Russia although although although also
the Americans they did not actually
expect Russian military to be as weak as
it appeared in Russia in the in the
Ukrainian theater of operation so I
think some of us we were already talking
about miscalculation by the Russians
maybe if they if they kept threatening
using Force could have been much better
for them than using Force itself because
most of the time if you threatened by
using force
it will you will have more perhaps
influence and pressure on your Rivals
than using Force itself now Russia use
Force actually and the West tested
Russia the West knows now very well the
Russian military capability and here you
go I mean they are doing everything
possible in order to defeat Russia and
according to Emmanuel macron yesterday
to defeat but not to crush Russia so
here is the here is another
miscalculation by President Putin
considering this whole conflict okay my
one Cameron stay with us
we're going to go now to this story
because China's top Diplomat is in
Russia to hold talks for Beijing it says
it's deeply worried about the escalating
conflict in Ukraine
we will continue to urge peace promote
talks and provide Chinese wisdom for a
political solution to the crisis in
Ukraine together with the International
Community we will jointly promote
dialogue negotiate and address the
concerns of all parties and seek a
common Security in the meantime we urge
certain countries to immediately stop
fueling the fire stop shifting blame to
China and stop piping up Ukraine today
and Taiwan tomorrow
What's China's role in all of this then
could it provide some kind of Peace plan
or just inflame matters
if you remember Khan last last year
before the invasion because the Russian
invasion of Ukraine Vladimir Putin
visited Beijing
and he met with Xi Jinping the Chinese
president it was during the Olympic
Games uh just a couple of weeks before
the invasion of Ukraine and many were
actually wondering whether he informed
the Chinese leadership about his
intention to invade Ukraine or or not
the Chinese that of course I mean
denying that they they have been
informed by directions about this but
since then there has been many questions
about where really China stand
concerning this conflict are they really
supporting Russia so far the U.S saying
that the Chinese are not trying to to
provide direct Military Support to the
Russians but they are buying Russian oil
and Russian gas and we all know that
Russia has more than doubled its
supplies of oil and gas to the Chinese
and they are selling them at a reduced a
price now the Americans because of the
recent tension between the United States
says and Nasha between the United States
and China China because of Taiwan and
because of the recent spy balloons which
has been shot by the U.S a couple of
weeks a couple of days ago the thing the
high tension with the Chinese is leading
the Americans to believe that that might
bring China even closer to Russia
concerning the war in Ukraine because
the Chinese are not really they don't
really want to see Russia defeated in
Ukraine because that will leave them
alone facing the United States
now Russia is relying more on China
Russia is becoming a junior partner for
the Chinese and the Chinese would want
actually to have now perhaps some sort
of a peaceful solution to this conflict
rather than seeing Russia defeated in
Ukraine okay thank you you mentioned
America there and in fact